[Music]  Zooey Deschanel gives birth to baby  number two I feel great I'm it's a great  accomplishment I can't believe it  Congrats are in order for the new girls  star and her husband Jacob ET can  confirm the 37 year old actress welcomed  their second child a baby boy the proud  parents named their son Charlie wolf how  his motherhood or fatherhood treating  you both  it's sleepless but wonderful the newborn  joins his big sister Elsie otter who  turns 2 in July  Zoe's rep tells us quote Zoe Jacob and  their daughter Elsie are overjoyed to  welcome the newest member of their  family it's the best it's so wonderful  I'm in love with my baby  [Music]